(raffut)
-
envahi le palais présidentiel,
les bureaux du premiisisisistre
sont pris d'assaut
par des manifestants.
Rajapaksa, est en fuite.
Il a désigné son premier
ministre, Ranil Wickremesinghe,
Il est encore trop proche
du clan ksksksksa.
La colère persiste.
"Nous sommes des citoyens
riririri Lanka. Nous sommes
ici pour sauver notre pays",
dit cet homme. L L L L L L L L s
d'habitants est au bord
de l'implosion. Fortement
endetté, le gouvernement
pour importer les produits
de base comme le pétrole.
ARK BRADLEY, Centre études Inde,
As
- Il y a une faillite de l'État
et là, les tabletntntntnt vides,
les produits de consommation
ne sont plus distribués. n n n e
fonctionnent plus, les tuktuk,
les voitures privées, les
camions, tout ça, c'est mort.
et de népotisme, Rajapaksa
est le dernier du clan qui aura
depuis deux décennies.
Même si le président du
parlement assure que Rajapaksann
n'a été confirmé.
(tirs)tititititititititititititt
donné le mandat au président
par intérim de rétablir
la loi et l'ordre.
pas, comme président, de pouvoir
lui-même un nouveau président.
- Au même m
la diaspora sraiseaiseaiseaise
célèbre la déesse Durga,
avec l'inquiétude amamamamamama.
"Ils ne savent pas là-basèèèèèt
avoir de l'eau, s'il vont avoir
de l'électricité,", dit cette
jeune Montréalaise d'origine
- L'eau sacrée purifie
les fidèles, comme une métaphore
de
dans leur pays d'origine.- La m,
on est tous contents que ça
arrive, pa
pour arriver. Ne baissez pas les
bras, on est presque à la
- Une fin imprévisible :
un couvre-feu a été imposé
L'armée sri lankaise appelle
à une résolution politique.
L'élection d'un nouveau chef
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau
Radadadadada, Montréa